so why do we care about the market
revolution the industrial revolution and
the transportation and communication
revolutions of the early 19th century
had a major impact on american society
both in the short term and in the long
term
in this video i want to talk about three
major effects of the market revolution
and those were changes in
labor
entry into a national and international
market system
and the second great awakening
all right so what effect did the market
revolution have on labor
well we've already talked about this a
little bit in the earlier videos
but here's a
view of a textile factory floor now this
is from a slightly later period but i
think it gives you a good sense of what
it was like to work in a textile factory
with the market revolution really comes
the emergence of factory labor in the
united states
and there are a couple of of ways that
that's important one is that people
start working for wages
it's a move away from subsistence
farming and a barter economy
which also means that
people aren't necessarily in charge of
themselves anymore
and there's a lot that goes along with
that which means that people stop being
their own bosses
instead they report to other bosses
and
that can be problematic
because
it means that you have a lot less
control over your daily life
so imagine that you're a farmer and
you're really sick
oh well you know maybe you don't plant
some seed that day
and you do it the next day well imagine
that you work at a textile mill and you
get really sick you don't report to work
and you get fired so people are no
longer able to set the pace of their own
lives by and large
and with things like interchangeable
parts
for example
fewer and fewer artisans
so masters of a craft
are making goods from start to finish so
it used to be perhaps you would be a
a master shoemaker a master cobbler and
you would make every part of that shoe
from tanning the leather to
nailing in the soul
the system of interchangeable parts
which
will later become even more codified as
the assembly line system
means that
most people are only doing one part of a
task so instead of doing all of making a
shoe and saying at the end of it i made
this shoe i'm a master maker of shoes
now your entire job might just be to
hammer in
one nail
and then hand off the shoe to the next
person so there's never anything that
you can point to and say i made that so
a lot of people say that this is a a
period when people stop being able to
take pride
in their own work
or at least not as much pride
but what's even more important about
this process
of interchangeable parts assembly line
labor is that it leads to an overall
what they call de-skilling
so removing the skill
from labor
and what's important about that is that
if
you've broken down a task into enough
small parts that you've got people
literally hammering in
the same nail on a different shoe
12 hours a day
then you don't necessarily need highly
trained
artisans to do that
and what happens
if
you are not highly trained
i would call this unskilled labor
and you decide you want to strike for
higher pay
well your boss doesn't need to train
anyone to hammer in that nail so you
just get fired so it makes the labor
force in general a little bit more
precarious because you don't need an
exceptional skill to have a factory job
but you are
easily replaced
all right let's talk about entry into a
market system
now what do i mean by this in this time
period the united states develops what's
called a market economy
and that's different from
what most people had been doing up until
that point because
people in the united states had mainly
shipped raw materials
over to
europe
england particularly
to be processed and made into finished
goods and this is similar to the system
of mercantilism that you might be
familiar with from the colonial era
well the war of 1812 and some of the
conflict leading up to it led the united
states to
embargo
england which was a manufacturing center
so people couldn't send their raw
materials there they responded by
investing in their own factories
so the war of 1812 is actually a pretty
important moment for the development of
domestic industrialization at home
and so now instead of this kind of
import export
or barter economy
people are making deals
with
other investors all over the united
states all over the world
so this gives people an opportunity to
invest
and
to speculate
and that means that
as they're part of a international
market of investment speculation
they're prone to the kinds of booms and
busts
that character characterize capitalism
right
now we often think of the great
depression as having been the first
major american depression but really it
was the largest and
most recent up until that point because
after the war of 1812 the united states
kind of goes through approximately a
20-year cycle
of boom and bust so boom is when things
are getting better things are looking up
the economy is going really well and
then a bubble of some kind bursts and in
1819 they had the very first of these
bubbles bursts called the panic of 1819
um
in land speculation and this is the
first time that the united states had
actually experienced any kind of
economic depression so imagine
how frightening that would have been to
them
one of the hardest things about
market-based capitalism is that
individuals don't really have control
over the larger market you know it's not
one person that made the great
depression happened was an overall loss
in consumer confidence or perhaps over
production right if too many people are
supplying the same commodity the price
is dropping through the laws of supply
and demand
so now the laws of supply and demand and
the pressures of an international market
are really changing the nature of
american commerce because they're
enmeshed in that market and that has all
kinds of
political and social ramifications for
the united states
now understanding the volatility of
belonging to
an international market kind of helps
explain why andrew jackson was so
obsessed with the national bank at this
time period right because it represents
this confusing matrix of international
supply and demand and people getting
credit or not getting credit
and being part of this international
market is something that's going to have
a major effect on the american south and
particularly the enslaved population
that lives in the american south because
they're going to be supplying cotton to
the world's textile mills and those are
textile mills in new england and textile
mills in england and as the world
demands cotton for processing the south
is going to supply that cotton which is
picked by enslaved individuals
and one of the reasons that the
confederacy believes that it can succeed
as an independent nation is because
they're supplying cotton to england and
when england managed to find its own
supply of cotton from
egypt and india
the economic chances of the confederacy
were sunk
and the last thing that i think is
related to this market revolution is the
second great awakening now i don't want
to go into too much detail about this
because of a whole separate series of
videos about the second great awakening
but this second great awakening was a
kind of an explosion of religious fervor
which was happening
at almost exactly the same time as the
market revolution
and many american historians actually
think that it's these confusing and
confounding and anxious forces that lead
a lot of people to take up religion
because as the world is changing around
them as people now have to relate in
different ways to their neighbors as
bosses and employees rather than
bartering partners and as they're swept
up in
international markets that are outside
their control
you know people look for
new explanations
and comfort
in an increasingly confusing world
so that's one explanation for the second
great awakening
so i started out this series of videos
by saying that some historians have
argued that the market revolution was
actually more revolutionary than the
american revolution now that's a
difficult question to answer because
we're talking about a revolution in
politics as opposed to kind of a
revolution of economics
but i will say that though the american
revolution dissolved the political bonds
between the united states and great
britain
its social and economic impact were
relatively limited most people kind of
ended up in the same place
socially after the the american
revolution as they were before it but
the market revolution
changes an awful lot in american society
in terms of
how they participate
internationally and how people organize
their daily lives so i think there is a
strong argument to be made that this
revolution of economics technology even
religion is considerably farther
reaching than the american revolution